Fox News Alert Elon Musk has officially
terminated his 44 billion dollar deal to
buy Twitter mosque reporter Lee saying
Twitter has dramatically misrepresented
the number of spam accounts on the site
and that Twitter did not provide him
with relevant business information
he requested so Jessica you thought this
was a big troll from the beginning have
you been Vindicated I hope so I think so
I hope you guys agree as well uh it
overall it seems like no one wants
Twitter and that Elon Musk you know
wanted to get into the conversation
about this he probably at one point
wanted it but then when he saw what
happened to Tesla on the other side he
was like well this is actually a lot
more valuable than owning the Public
Square as it were
um this waving due diligence and then
not getting the information that you
wanted when you waived the diligence in
the first place uh Ring's a little
Hollow to me and I think he's just had a
you know several weeks months now of bad
press and it's just going to skulk away
from all of this and go back to building
rockets and cool cars so Greg are the
people at Twitter headquarters crying
for Joy today instead of in sadness not
really the first time think of the
reason why musk is the richest person on
earth is he finds more than one way to
win do you know what I mean so he buys
Twitter he wins he doesn't buy Twitter
he still won because he did a number of
things he exposed
some of the hugest fallacies about this
about Twitter being fair or Twitter
being free he's an engineer he went in
he kicked the tires he looked under the
hood and he let everybody else take a
look at it at the same time so he got it
he basically what he was a bull in a
china shop but he was an engineer in a
china shop and he showed what's in there
and what's broken so I think you know
what
I don't know I'm kind of sad because it
would have been fun but at the same time
I learned a lot you know I hope we can
still be friends so judge the market is
closed right now but do you think that
this will tank twitters
yeah talk on Monday yeah I really do
um and you know I'm disappointed like
Greg I really am I like the idea of
someone coming in and talking about free
speech and telling people you know
you're not going to have a crying room
anymore and someone who was Pro First
Amendment uh you know and but you know
we knew I think a month ago well I think
more than a month ago that there was an
issue as to the Bots and the spam and
all that stuff was it is it greater than
five percent and it appeared that
Twitter was not willing to identify or
give him the information that he needed
uh and so you know as Greg said the
analogy looked under the hood but I
don't know if they allowed him to really
look under the hood so
um the question is is he being
sanctioned now does he lose money was
there a penalty in there if an automatic
one if he doesn't go forward so why why
are you showing me that these are the
questions for fan mail
it's better really worth anything it's
like
don't put your faith in anyone not a
billionaire not a politician people
don't come in and just save the day like
that the big thing for me that always
smelled fishy about this is that he
cozied up to Jack yeah and like even the
rhetoric coming from debt so it's like
did he have did he think he had some
inside information and he thought it was
calculated and now that's not going to
work I don't know it's all speculation
wow she's throwing things at me Greg
Gutfeld over here she's throwing stuff
back all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else